but what really blew my mind is you can
ask it to summarize YouTube videos and
this is really useful especially when
the videos along like this podcast which
was an hour and 12 minutes all you do is
select the link hit that copy button and
once again in chat GPT ask it to
summarize this video then paste the link
but importantly head on back to YouTube
video and also copy the title and then
paste that title just below the link
it's not gonna lie without using the
title you can sometimes get some mixed
results but once again instantly it
gives you a summary of what was actually
in the video without having to spend an
hour and 12 minutes oh boy have you
noticed that the tsunami of AI
sweeping across the internet lately I'm
not here to roast this particular
YouTuber but she's a perfect example of
the chaos unfolding I'm starting to get
where Gary Marcus is coming from ranting
about the flood of misinformation and
folks not putting their thinking caps on
when they dabble with AI models this
YouTuber seems to have missed the memo
on how GPT Works newsflash GPT does not
access the internet so when you ask it
to summarize a URL it's just making wild
guesses based on the URL alone like a
psychic at a fair The ai's Parlor trick
is in full swing and we're all invited
to the circus
now nuclear warheads are scary enough
but AI isn't going to be a little
smarter than Einstein it's going to be a
lot smarter not five times smarter or 10
times smarter or even 10 000 times
smarter we're talking millions of times
smarter as unlikely as you think this
might be what is what would be your best
explanation right now or why something
like this might happen
you really want them to be reliable and
they ended up not being reliable or if
reliability they're not to be harder
than we expect I really don't think that
will be the case but if I had to pick
one if I had to pick one and you tell me
like hey like why didn't things work out
it would be reliability that you still
have to look over the answers and double
check everything and that's just really
puts a damper on the economic value that
can various by those systems even if I
believe this sort of mysticism that it's
somehow emergent in there you would at
least have to grant me that there's
nobody that has any clue right now how
to pull that out of the system and say
you know we had this discourse with chat
gpt4 and we're now going to interrogate
it in the way that we interrogate our
navigation system and we'll say this is
the representation of things that's not
something people can do in my view it
can't be done because you're just in
extensional space learning relations
between sentences but even if I were
wrong like you don't have that
Gary just put a piece out called gpt5 an
irrational exuberance uh you'll
recognize the image he uses of the first
step fallacy which is to say building a
taller Tower expecting to get closer to
the moon and um he actually quotes
elieza udkowski our friend that we've
been speaking about recently he posted
on Twitter only a few days ago that he
thought the scary thing about gpt4 is
that it understands what it means when
you say compress this in a way where you
can decompress it someone prompted gbt
in such a way to kind of invent its own
compression language I thought the idea
sounded interesting so I tried to
compress a BBC News article and as you
can see it gave me this confection of
emoticons and code words and I asked it
to uncompress it and it just made a
Litany of mistakes for example the
original article said that Peter Muriel
58 is being questioned after being taken
into police custody and that became 58
people had been arrested so in my mind
that demonstrates that GPT doesn't
understand the content deeply and Gary
Marquez said that this is it's another
example of people like yukowski falling
for anecdotal data now might be a good
time to mention by the way that Gary has
got a new podcast coming out called
humans vs machines the first episode is
dropping in about two weeks there's a
preview episode up there now so you can
listen to that and get a taste for some
of the guests that he's inviting on but
he's got some amazing people on there so
uh go and subscribe now and check that
out when it comes out I'd really like
you to put this moment
equal context how did we get
so people have been trying to build AI
for 75 years most of it hasn't worked
not too much of it has been practical we
all use GPS systems turn-by-turn
navigation I use GPS to get get here
today it worked successfully and so
there's some AI that we take for granted
that we've been using for years Google
search is driven by AI we take that for
granted it's not sexy Ai and it's not
very general purpose the dream is to
build general purpose AI that can do
anything for you I would say we're not
actually there yet but we now have the
illusion that we're there and that
illusion has been very compelling to a
lot of people so historically we've had
things like chess computers that only
play chess or we have Alpha fold here
here in London that folds proteins but
doesn't do anything else and people have
hand crafted solutions for many
individual problems sometimes
successfully sometimes not and here
walks in these GPT things generalized
pre-trained Transformers they've
actually been around for a few years I
guess they were introduced four years
ago were thereabouts
and they got a lot of hype in the field
before
gpt3 actually got a fair amount of hype
the guardian here in the UK had an op-ed
that they alleged was written by gpt3
the reality behind the scenes was there
was an editor tweaking it which I think
they acknowledged in a footnote or
something like that but that was
certainly a lot of press and it was
pressed in the New York Times magazine
about it that was very enthusiastic but
they limited the release of it and it
was still more of a like academics play
with this isn't this kind of cool thing
um then a couple interesting things
happened in November the first one was
that
meta released Galactica and Galactica is
actually not that different from chat
GPT or gpt4 it can do some of the same
things but it also was prone to saying a
lot of misleading things maybe we'll
talk about that later it was taken off
the market after three days it vanished
like a stone I guess I have to say at
least a little bit just for context it
was it would say things like somebody
would type in write an essay about the
benefits of eating crushed glass and it
would write something that was fully
plausible and explain that experiments
have been conducted in order to see
whether the benefits arose from the
phosphorus content or something else
like it was it was really persuasive
stuff and a lot of people including me
got upset about it and said hey you know
this hasn't been carefully vetted why
have you put it out there and they took
it down and then maybe a week after that
or two weeks after that chat GPT came
out and chat TPT is a very similar
underlying technology basically what
these things do is they take in massive
amounts of data and they in some way
kind of mimic that data we can get into
the details of how they don't really
understand the world but they have so
much data that they can sound persuasive
at times and chatgpt differed from
Galactica because it had two things one
is it had guard rails in place the guard
rails would keep it from saying really
dumb stuff so most likely if you asked
it about the benefits of crushed glass
of eating crushed glass it might
actually avoid the question sometimes in
silly ways we can get there too
but it was at least an effort to take
seriously the problem that these systems
can produce toxic content and they
released it to everybody instead of
doing in a controlled small release to a
few academics or corporate partners that
they put it out there in the whole world
and it went viral I don't think anybody
including open AI who released it
expected that it would grow as fast as
it did it grew faster than anything any
consumer product in history I think and
that's my next question why hasn't
somebody like you with all your skills
in imagination and using about 17 and a
half percent of your brain is against
the ten why haven't you figured out how
to mechanically work like the human
brain it doesn't seem that artificial
well there's I mean there's a couple of
different things one is we might not
actually want our machines to work just
like the human brain we probably want to
borrow some things from the brain and
not others so for example the human
brain is terrible at memory so we forget
where we parked our car there have been
people known to jump out of uh airplanes
and forget to pull the rip cord so you
know the bad memory kills them
um there are lots of problems with human
memory I actually wrote a book called
cluge which is about all the limits of
the human mind another one is
confirmation bias we notice things that
support our theories but not that go
against them and in politics that's a
disaster because we can't get along with
each other because we're all looking at
different data because we only see the
data that supports our own Theory so we
don't want to make a copy of the human
brain but there is stuff we would like
to learn about it and it's just really
complicated and you think of billions of
neurons and trillions of connections we
don't even know what to look at I would
say until three years ago we didn't even
have the right tools to get started
because we were looking at whole areas
of the brain like 70 000 neurons at once
be one pixel in these images you've
probably seen an analogy I used in New
Yorkers that's like trying to understand
politics by looking outside of an
airplane window you're just too far away
from the action so in the last couple of
years we've gotten closer to the action
we can look at individual neurons but we
can't look at that many we have to open
your skull to do it and the things that
are most interesting to us are really
things like language because we happen
to be human beings and we don't really
want to cut open people's skulls to do
the experiments we might need to do to
find out so
um it's it's going to take a lot of work
some of it is maybe unethical so we
don't want to do it so there's a lot of
obstacles to figuring out the brand
religions and the human brain is
actually a lot of different things
visual intelligence and verbal
intelligence mathematical intelligence
so there are many aspects to it but
maybe the most important one is
flexibility being able to see something
new and be able to cope with it human
intelligence is full of flaws we have
confirmation bias we have lousy memories
but it's flexible and part part of it is
that we can reason about things we can
deliberate about them most of machine
intelligence that we have right now is
really about pattern recognition so for
now I would say that human intelligence
is broader than machine intelligence in
some places machines can go deeper like
when they play chess but I don't think
they have the breadth so far that humans
do some some humans have started beating
the go algorithms again because they've
kind of discovered an adversarial attack
it's the Swiss cheese problem you know
when you're in a hole in the Swiss
cheese the Deep learning models Go
Bananas it's the it's the equivalent of
hallucinating in in the in the game
domain but you know there's this very
interesting
um dichotomy I wanted you to think about
which is that there's almost an
orthogonality between intelligence and
understanding so we understand go better
than alphago because we have a more
abstract understanding of go as Gary was
speaking to in in the Sam Harris podcast
and yet the algorithms can apparently be
more intelligent than us so it leads to
this kind of Cartesian plane of
intelligences where you have knowing and
thinking if you like the go example for
example which is you know phenomenally
interesting science and I was very
excited about this okay firstly why why
is go a particularly challenging problem
for people because actually just
literally the state Vector as you would
say in AI the the board size is just
extremely large and it's just at the
limit of what people can mentally cope
with which is why explicitly for humans
explicitly reasoning about go is
actually really quite hard for them to
do which is why you know there are these
kind of semi-mystical essays about how
the go players think about uh about how
they play go
um the go playing programs are famous
alphago and so on
um it is not a mapping from strings to
Strings but it's a mapping from board
positions to moves and it is not
dissimilar in the sense that there's
just an enormous amount of training data
where the program is basically optimized
to select the move with the highest
probability of leading to a win state I
mean that's an oversimplification and
all my friends in deepmind are now
groaning that I said that but that's
roughly speaking it's just a heavily
heavily heavily optimized program to do
that thing now the the training data and
so on and the training algorithms within
that
LED it to one particular uh policy I
mean that's what it's learning it's
learning a policy about doing this the
adversarial attacks are finding a route
around that policy basically which is
not tremendously surprising I mean I
think it's very cute what's done and I
don't mean you know I think it uh I
smiled when I read about those those
stories just everybody else did but not
tremendously surprising but I think what
it's saying is
roughly speaking most of AI programs at
the moment are just these programs which
are heavily optimized in in the case of
large language models with unimaginable
amounts of training data an unimaginable
amounts of compute power like 10 to the
23 floating Point operations for for
gpt3 or something which is a number
that's so large it's actually just kind
of meaningless for human beings all
optimized to do a mapping from uh from
the board position to a move or from a
string to a string in the case of a
large language model and that's all
they're doing I mean they're simply
heavily optimized to do that uh does
meaning and understanding emerge out of
that and when when will we know when
we've done it well I think we're going
to have a panel this afternoon we're
going to get to discuss this
um you know our Lang our large language
models part of the ingredient for AI for
the larger vision of AI which Gary is
very passionate about and I've grown up
up with
um uh and the jury is out I think I mean
they are certainly interesting but
whether they are going to lead to
understanding in any meaningful sense I
think is the jury's very much out should
we be puritanical when we say
understanding you know Melanie Mitchell
has this modes of understanding paper
and we have a very anthropocentric view
of understanding and it's getting to the
point now where the large language
models aren't just performing very very
well on so many Downstream tasks at what
point does mimicry basically for all
intents and purposes be the same as
understanding I mean I I view this from
the lens of a cognitive psychologist and
the important part of the cognitive
Revolution was that you have to think
about the mental states of the system
you're trying to understand you can't
just look at Behavior now it is possible
in principle that you get to something
that is behaviorally identical to a
person but still uses different
architecture to get there certainly
large language models work really
differently from people I don't care
what like Neuroscience mumbo jumbo I've
seen out there they just don't work the
same they're not doing recourse to
mental models that they're testing
assessing updating and so forth this is
not what they do what they do is they
predict sequences of words
um even if you got to like GPT 10 and it
made fewer errors it's still not a I
mean if it follows the architecture that
three does and I should have a asterisk
that we don't actually know the
architecture of four but on the
assumption that 10 was consistent with
three I would say no there's still not
mental states there this is not how it
works you have to think about what is
the architecture here what are the
computations
um you can also like do empirical things
and say is there some representation
here that corresponds to like the word
third for example
um so like people have done a bunch of
interesting things lately on Twitter
last few days trying out does GPT
understand words like give me the third
character in the third word in the
sentence and it's performance on these
things is not really reliable you are
not going to be able to find for me a
universal representation of third across
all uses that it's actually going to get
correct I'm not sure that's ever going
to be solid I think there's always going
to be a distribution shift problem it's
and let me give you philosophical terms
um philosophers sometimes talk about
intention and extension and so the
intention of knowing what an odd number
is different from a list of what all the
odd numbers are and we find that these
systems often get tripped up on this so
they'll recognize a lot of odd numbers
because they know something about the
extension what are the odd numbers in
the world but then they make wacky
mistakes because something isn't in the
training set my favorite paper in the
last couple years in some ways is
yazaman razeji if I can say her name and
and Samir sings paper where they took
gptj where we actually had their
training set and check out our interview
with them that's right I think I
endorsed it I'm not sure I saw it but I
know the paper
um you know what they did and you had
there is they looked at a place where
you have the training set and that
allows you to ask the question of how
sensitive is the result to the relation
between the training data and the test
data which if you look back at my own
work has been Central since 1998 and
really since since 1992 since my first
publication it it's always been about
what is the relation between the test
set and the training day that's the only
way you can find out
what a system actually does you can't
just look at the behavioral output give
me another moment here you can't just
look at the behavioral outputs no you
have to do things like look at error
analysis you have to understand the
relation but between the training and
the test and we literally cannot do that
for gpc4 because we don't know what the
training is but there she actually had
available could do real science and when
she did the real science it was obvious
that it doesn't really have a
representation of say multiplication
that it can use in a general way it's
tied to the extension to the cases that
it's seen I'm not going to Grant
conceptual understanding of uh
multiplication to A system that can't do
that come on I'll bring Michael in but
just just to comment on that I I agree
with you I'm always citing the
connectionism critique from photo and
position and talking about how we lose
those intentional attributes in the
neural network because they get lost
Downstream but you know these arguments
about that lack of capabilities of
finite state automatism in the context
of neural networks doesn't seem to fly
really when we have research on
in-context learning which came after Joe
for example in context learning you can
actually do extrapolative
um Edition I think or multiplication and
and also some of the work now we're
seeing with retrieval augmented
generation and just the general human
augmentation I still think it's a straw
man to think about language models on
their own Let me Give an example gpt4 I
did a three-hour podcast the other day I
fed it into gpt4 in 15-minute chunks I'd
asked gpt4 to generate a Python program
to transcribe it using whisper to create
a table of contents and references I
then asked gpt4 to collate it all
together into an overall set of
references I then asked gbt Forge to
generate a Python program to nudge all
of the indexes and generate an index
file so I could import it into my video
editor I mean this is just an insane
level of scripting complexity I wouldn't
have it wouldn't I wouldn't have
conceived of doing that before gpt4 and
now it's done it for me and yeah I'm
fixing problems as I go but do you see
what I mean it's me with the model it's
not just the model on its own yeah I
completely agree I mean I think and what
you're saying is these things can be
useful but I think we just we need to
we're dazzled when we see them and it's
very easy to imagine that there is
understanding there but for all the
reasons that we're discussing now I
think there isn't I mean I will throw
one other one other thing in and this is
my standard example so
um ask gpt4 to describe an omelet or to
give you a recipe for an omelette and
it's read thousands of omelette recipes
and thousands of reviews of omelette
restaurants or whatever
um and uh and it's ingested all of that
and it will come out with a uh it'll
come out with a perfectly decent
omelette recipe and it will probably be
able to describe the texture of an
omelette using terms that sound terribly
plausible doesn't understand anything
about omelets no of course it doesn't I
mean when you when I talk about an
omelette
um what that means to me is every
experience that I've ever had with an
omelette in the world like for The
Omelette I had for breakfast this
morning The Omelette I had in a parrot
Parisian Restaurant in 1997. you know
the omelettes that I burn on a regular
basis when I try and cook them at home
it actually that my experience my
understanding of that term is actually
grounded in my experiences in the real
world
um ingesting countless numbers of Words
which are words that we use to describe
those experiences does not add up to the
same experience could I just push back
on that tiny bits up so yeah some of it
is the ontological subjective so it's
it's how you felt when you were in all
of these experiences but there's also
this second rung on the ladder which is
a much more objective understanding
which is shared in our culture and
language and so on and um it's
understanding to you just about fidelity
I yeah let me insert one thing first so
there's like two sets of questions here
are these models useful the answer is
yes with a lot of caveats around they
hallucinate they're not always accurate
and so forth but of course you can use
them and then there's a question about
what it is that they represent and I I'm
firm in saying they don't have real
world models they have some kind of
approximation maybe that sort of works
but they don't represent or like this is
magical myth of emergence but like even
multiplication in Minerva that was
trained on you know however many
billions examples like it gets two-digit
multiplication but it doesn't get four
digit multiplication you always see this
Hallmark of extensional reasoning and
not intentional reasoning or that's not
quite the right words but you know
success on the extensional stuff that is
close to the trading set and then you
always see a distribution problem you
don't get something abstract the way
that humans have for example the word
same we can take the word same and apply
it to so many different things like are
those two cameras the same are these two
microphones are the these two cups the
same we have this very general concept
that we can apply in essentially a
universal way in fact in my 2001 book I
talked about universally Quantified
one-to-one mappings and I said with a
given architecture which was more
primitive than Transformers that you
would not be able to solve universally
Quantified one-to-one mappings because
of the local nature of the learning Rule
and that's still true and we still see
ways in which that plays out even now
like I wrote this paper in 1998 25 years
later somebody the other day did my
example it rose has a rose a Dax is a
blank and instead of saying it Dax as a
Dax which will be obvious to any human
being it said like I'm sorry I can't
talk about fictional words or something
like that so this was gpt4 failing this
task that I devised 25 years ago and
everything else is actually an extension
of this problem of distribution shift
and so if you want to talk to me about
do they have abstracted World models I
think the answer is no and it's it's
kind of looking for a hopeful monster
and I notice
um Michael nodding his his agreement on
that
um I just it's just not happening we
need a different architecture so now the
last piece your question a precise World
Model A system that can derive a precise
World model that you could let's say run
through an API and interrogate from
language that's a major Advance if we
could have something that could take
just like descriptions of what's going
on in this room
excuse me
be able to abstract them to a world
model that you can interrogate and you
could say where does the person think
that there are chairs where does the
person excuse me think that there are
tables
does the person think that the tripod is
supporting the camera you could answer
that all those kinds of questions yes
then you would have a role model